le parlement doit se prononcer d'ici la
fin de l'année sur le budget 2021 et
2027 de l'union européenne et pour
gilbert casasus professeur d'études
européennes à l'université bilingue de
fribourg les reproches exprimés par le
parlement européen à l'encontre de
l'union européenne elles peuvent être
justifiées qui veulent faire pression
sachant que le parlement européen essaye
de plus en plus d'être un acteur
déterminant dans le cadre de la prise de
décision de l'union européenne
il y a aussi des reproches justifier que
le parlement européen peut avoir à
l'encontre ou petit exprimé avoir à
l'encontre de l'accord cela concerne
notamment des coupes budgétaires
et je parle là plutôt des coupes
budgétaires dans le cadre des mesures
pour l'environnement et aussi le non
respect d'après beaucoup de
parlementaires européens
la règle du droit sachant qu organe et
la pologne
donc la hongrie et la pologne ont obtenu
une formulation assez vague sur la
question du respect de l'état de droit
dans le cadre de l'union européenne de
la syrie à la libye en passant par les
îles de chypre ou de lesbos les sujets
de dissension on ne manque pas entre la
france et la turquie ce jeudi emmanuel
macron a dénoncé la violation des
souverainetés grecs et chypriotes par la
turquie en méditerranée orientale et
détails avec jordi demory la tension ne
retourne pas en mer méditerranée la
marine grecque a été mise en état d'
alerte ce mercredi après que la turquie
a dépêché des navires de guerre à
proximité de l'île kastellorizo les
bateaux turcs accompagner un bâtiment
d'exploration gazière sous marine une
attitude condamnée ce jeudi par emmanuel
macron alors qu'il recevait son
homologue chypriote dans cette partie de
la méditerranée qui est vital pour tous
nos pays les questions énergétiques et
de sécurité sont aujourd'hui essentielle
elles sont l'enjeu de luttes de
puissance en particulier de la turquie
et de la russie qui s'affirme de plus en
plus et face auxquels l'union européenne
pèse encore trop peu ce serait une grave
erreur que de laisser notre sécurité en
méditerranée aux mains d'autres acteurs
cela n'est pas une option pour l'europe
est en tout cas ça n'est pas quelque
chose que la france ait sera faire les
tensions entre la turquie et la france
sont montés d'un cran juin dernier un
incident maritime entre deux bâtiments
de guerre turcs et français a relancé
les dissensions
la grèce a elle assuré qu'elle était
prête à défendre ses droits souverains
contre tout type de menace
après les manoeuvres d'ankara notre
gouvernement souligne que l'annoncent
d'activités d'exploration turque dans
certaines parties du plateau continental
grecs avec des marins en situation
irrégulière constitue une escalade de la
tension dans la région
dans le même temps cela montre les
actions hostiles continuelle de la
turquie et son mépris total du droit
international de son côté la russie a
appelé au dialogue les différentes
parties impliquées dans les conflits de
cette région du globe
nous suivons attentivement et avec
inquiétude la nouvelle escalade de
tension en méditerranée orientale
nous préconisons le règlement des
divergences par la négociation sur la
base des normes universelles reconnu du
droit international et nous appelons les
différentes parties à oeuvrer pour
renforcer le retour de la confiance et
des relations de bon voisinage et aussi
à s'abstenir totalement de prendre des
mesures unilatérales y réfléchisse pour
résoudre efficacement les différents qui
se manifeste il existe la plate forme
universelle qui est l'organisation des
nations unies en outre le mécanisme de
délimitation des zones économiques
exclusives et du plateau continental
entre les états est stipulé dans la
convention des nations unies sur le
droit de la mer de 1982 la france
devrait accueillir un sommet de
l'alliance des pays du sud
de l'union européenne nommé med 7 pour
évoquer la situation en méditerranée
orientale
l'espagne le portugal l'italie la grèce
malte et chypre y participeront à la fin
du mois d'août ou au début du mois de
septembre
olivier delorme historien auteur de la
grèce et les balkans aux éditions
gallimard souligne et potentiels
sanctions encourues par la turquie
d'abord il peut y avoir la suspension
voire l'arrêt dieu de la négociations
d'adhésion de la turquie à l'union
européenne qui devient franchement
ubuesque dans la mesure où ce pays à
grèce occupe une partie d'un membre de
l'union européenne qui s'appelle chypre
et en agressent deux autres puisque ses
provocations
elles ont également lieu dans les eaux
chypriotes donc ce processus d'adhésion
de la turquie devrait être immédiatement
arrêtées si les européens voulaient être
un peu crédible et puis ensuite vous
avez tout une toute une série de
sanctions économiques et financières
entretien téléphonique entre donald
trump et vladimir poutine aujourd'hui
selon un communiqué du kremlin les deux
hommes ont discuté en détail des
questions liées à la stabilité
stratégique et la maîtrise des armements
contenu la responsabilité particulière
que la russie et les etats unis ont dans
le domaine du maintien de la paix de la
sécurité internationales la situation
autour du programme nucléaire iranien a
été évoqué les
les deux chefs d'état espère aussi est
l'organisation d'un sommet des pays
membres permanents du conseil de
sécurité des nations unies sur un large
éventail de problèmes de sécurité
internationales jean yves le drian au
liban pour deux jours pays ravagé par
une crise économique sans précédent plus
de la moitié de la population vit sous
le seuil de pauvreté
le ministre français des affaires
étrangères a rappelé l'engagement de la
france envers la population libanaise et
jean yves le drian réclament des
réformes attendues depuis trop longtemps
je suis venu porter ici un message de
vérité
l'heure est grave
le liban est dans une situation très
préoccupante
la crise économique et financière fait
rage elle a des conséquences concrètes
dramatique pour les libanais qui
s'appauvrissent de jour en jour la
france est prête à se mobiliser
pleinement aux côtés du liban et a
mobilisé l'ensemble de ses partenaires
mais il faut pour cela que des mesures
de redressement sérieuse et crédible
soit mise en oeuvre des actes concrets
sont attendus depuis trop longtemps et
comme je les dis récemment devant le
sénat français aidez nous à vous aider
ces mesdames et messieurs le maître mot
de ma visite à beyrouth et ce
déplacement d'un jean yves le drian et
de le premier depuis ces derniers mois
d'un haut responsable occidental dans un
pays en plein naufrage économique une
situation aggravée par la crise du
coronavirus c'est dans ce contexte que
les hôpitaux libanais sont de plus en
plus démunis les détails avec franck la
cavalière bien des coupures de courant
un manque de personnel dieu à des
salaires très faible ou encore des
équipements défectueux comme le reste de
l'économie
le secteur de la santé libanais est en
grande souffrance les hôpitaux publics
comme les cliniques privées doit
fonctionner avec très peu de ressources
et conséquence directe la sécurité des
patients est de plus en plus difficile à
assurer en pleine pandémie de
coronavirus certains établissements sont
ainsi obligés de refuser des malades
dont l'état est jugé non critiques
il y à des fournitures médicales
indispensables dont les stocks
commencent à s'épuiser dans les hôpitaux
il y à des médicaments qui commencent à
manquer
la situation est vraiment catastrophique
et nous nous attendons à subir bientôt
un effondrement total
si le gouvernement ne lance pas de plan
de sauvetage particulièrement menacé les
cliniques privées représentent pourtant
85% des services hospitaliers du liban
mais désormais elles n'ont plus les
moyens d'entretenir leur installation ou
deux
portez des fournitures coûteuses telles
que les produits nécessaires pour les
anesthésies les hôpitaux publics
redoutent d'être submergé en cas de
vague épidémique massive
malheureusement les cliniques privées
les hôpitaux publics et l'ensemble du
secteur de la santé souffre beaucoup
d'un manque d'équipements médicaux de
base comme les appareils respiratoires
et subissant plus des coupures de
courant qui ne les aide vraiment pas la
quasi faillite du système de santé n'est
qu'une des conséquences de la terrible
crise économique qui secoue le liban la
plus grave depuis la fin de la guerre
civile en 1990 le chômage dépasse les
30% et la pauvreté touche presque la
moitié des 7 millions d'habitants du
pays
mais la crise n'a fait qu'aggraver une
situation déjà très dégradées depuis
octobre 2019 les manifestations se
multiplient contre le gouvernement et la
classe politique pour ne pas sombrer
beyrouth espère obtenir un soutien
d'environ 10 milliards de dollars du fmi
les négociations m'ont toujours pas
abouti il faut être mode cole président
du rassemblement de dirigeants et chefs
d'entreprise libanais dans le monde
exprime un espoir concernant l'aide
française mais reste méfiant on écoute
le liban passe aujourd'hui par une des
périodes les plus dramatiques de son
histoire économique social monétaire et
à tous les niveaux
aujourd'hui tous les secteurs le secteur
public le secteur privé a été longtemps
un fer de lance un pylône central de
l'économie libanaise étant est
enseignements on a de l'espoir de la
visite du ministre français
on a de l'espoir mais en même temps on a
peur on a peur parce qu'on a vu que nos
gouvernements tous les gouvernements qui
se sont succédé sur les trente dernières
années
ce n'est pas la première fois qu'on
reçoit une aide ou un projet d'un
international mais pour rappel on a eu
la france qui a toujours été aux côtés
du liban qui a organisé en 2001 la
conférence de paris un suivi de paris 2
suivi de paris iii pour passer à côté
les conférences de sokol de londres de
bruxelles de rome et finalement aucune
des réformes promises
aucune des promesses de réformes qui ont
été faits par tous les gouvernements qui
se sont succédés n'ont pu les mettre en
place
on va prendre la direction de lions à
présent où les hommages à axel jeune
femme fauchée par une voiture dans la
nuit de samedi à dimanche se multiplient
un drame qui émeut la ville des lumières
j'ai de louise carvalho et ça y est le
bruit
une émotion toujours aussi vive à lyon
cinq jours après le drame qui a coûté la
vie à une jeune aide-soignante de 23 ans
de nombreux anonymes continuent de venir
lui rendre hommage sur les lieux du
drame
à deux pas de la basilique notre dame de
fourvière il dépose fleurs messages et
prières en mémoire de la jeune femme
j'étais très touché par ce drame je
trouve ça horrible et surtout que ça se
reproduise plus donc je me devais d'être
là pour aurel et puis pour les autres si
c'est vrai que j'étais prise avec
beaucoup d'émotion parce que étant donné
que je suis maman maman d'une
d'une jeune femme de 23 ans aussi qui
est toujours en sortie avec ses amis
et avec et je me dis que ben voilà ça
pour arriver à ma fille
fauché par une voiture dans la nuit de
samedi à dimanche
axel d'aurier a été traîné sous le
véhicule sur 800 m alors que l' enquête
est en cours
le conducteur du véhicule âgé de 21 ans
et son passager ont été mis en examen
dans la région lyonnaise les sentiments
de colère et d'incompréhension demeure
très vif ludovic kassi représentant
départemental du syndicat de police sgp
unité force ouvrière estime que ce fait
divers vient confirmer une hausse de
l'insécurité en france
je ne suis pas sûr que ce soit
uniquement le cas dès que le cas des
grandes villes des moyennes villes
également on a eu récemment des faits
d'une extrême violence sur sur dijon où
il ya eu des tirs à l'armé à feu nice
d'une ville un petit peu moins grande
que l'on a connu également en plein jour
des échanges des échanges de tirs larmes
de guerre le sentiment je pense que
c'est pas qu'un sentiment il ya des
faits de plus en plus quotidien dans nos
villes et dans notre dans notre pays
des faits qui marque l'ensemble des
français il reste à déterminer les
circonstances exactes de ce drame
selon le procureur de la république de
lyon le conducteur et son passager n'ont
pas d'antécédents judiciaires
les tests d'alcoolémie sont quant à eux
revenus négatifs
l'accord commercial post briques site
sera peu probable c'est ce qu'annonce
michel barnier pour le négociateur en
chef de l'union européenne sur le bric
site
l'heure n'est pas à l'optimisme
certaines grandes questions comme la
pêche ou la concurrence ont très peu
avancé selon
this mean chey me plaît tapez cela
signifie simplement que par son refus
actuel de s'engager à une concurrence
ouverte et libre et à un accord
équilibré sur la pêche le royaume uni
rentrent un accord commercial à ce stade
peu probable a disparu
on a écrit le bric site inspire d'autres
pays européens c'est le cas de l'italie
essayez la volonté est de gianluigi
paragon sénateurs crée aujourd'hui elles
sont parties appelées ita l'ex-site l
ancien journaliste de télévision a
présenté son projet deux jours après une
réunion à londres avec est le chef du
parti et à bréxent its et nigel farage
en italie il manque un parti qui propose
ouvertement une sortie de l'italie de
l'union européenne et de l'union
monétaire
sous son visage de modifier de corriger
de perfectionner l'europe et je leur dis
bonne chance
proposer une alternative politique de ce
type aux italiens aussi radicale qu'elle
soit est une manière de leur permettre
de s'exprimer sur ce projet et pour en
parler nous sommes en direct avec matteo
et alberti rédacteur en chef de m putsch
manière
bonsoir matteotti d'alberti merci d'être
avec nous sur rt france ce soir
italic site veut s'inspirer du parti de
nigel farage
on l'a vu mais au vu de la situation
économique du pays italie
peut-elle vraiment se passer de l'europe
effectivement de l'italie est très
ancrée en europe et non seulement du
point de vue économique mais aussi du
point de vue culturel et historique
cependant ces dernières années on a vu
que les italiens qui étaient un peuple
historiquement très europhile ont changé
d'avis sur l'union européenne
d'abord parce que elles se sont senties
abandonnées lors de la crise des
migrants et mais aussi
abandonné pendant la la montée du coc
fidh qui a provoqué des milliers
d'hommes en italie et à cette époque là
les pays européenne je parle de la début
de mars était plutôt discret plutôt et
regarder ailleurs
alors que l'italie était vraiment en
difficulté et les italiens ont retenu un
peu 7,7 les sons et garde un souvenir un
peu négatif de l'union européenne alors
cet homme gianluigi paragon comment est
il perçu on est à dix et on sait que
c'est un ancien journaliste de
télévision
comment comment on la préfère comment
est il perçu en italie tout simplement
gianluigi pentagone et est connu pour
avoir eu un passé dans des médias des
droites on peut on pourrait dire aussi
souverainiste donc on sait que sont sa
sensibilité dix ont été plutôt de droite
même s'il a rejoint effectivement le le
parti du mouvement 5 étoiles qui est
anti anti système anti cast et qui était
aussi un petit europe parce qu'il faut
pas oublier que beppe grillo son
fondateur à plusieurs reprises demandé
de laisser exprimer les italiens sur la
possibilité de quitter l'euro il l'avait
fait d'ailleurs même un canton
l'interview de putsch donc c'est
intéressant de voir que finalement il y
à un retour aux origines entre
guillemets de du mouvement 5 étoiles est
aussi un essai de comment dire d'attirer
vers cette nouvelle formation politique
et que pour l'instant selon les sondages
ne n'obtiendrait pas plus de 2% grosso
modo 2 et des votes mecs iraient
pourrait effectivement bénéficier du
mécontentement d'une partie de
l'électorat du mouvement 5 étoiles qui
ne se sentent plus représentés parce que
ce mouvement a choisi une déposition
beaucoup plus europhile et quelque chose
qui pourrait un peu compromette les
plans de cet homme c'est celle ce plan
de relance promis par l'union européenne
est ce qu'elle peut inverser les choses
et n'est-il pas trop tard du coup pour
gianluigi paragon et son parti puisque
selon un dernier sondage réalisé par swg
à la fin du mois de mai seulement 39 %
des italiens déclaré faire confiance à
l'union européenne mais c'est trop tard
non je pense parce que finalement on
verra
peut-être dz d'ici 2021
l'italie comme tous les pays qui ont été
durement frappés par le cos vide par
exemple la france ont besoin maintenant
de pouvoir compter sur des ressources et
économique et surtout les italiens ne
veulent pas du tout l'idée d'avoir été
considéré comme d un peu une espèce de
voleurs
parce qu'ils ont demandé de l'aide à
leurs partenaires principaux et surtout
on a réalisé que il ya quelques semaines
il ya eu une émission de titres d'état
le btp et c'était cette émission était
particulièrement positive donc dans
certains milieux on se dit bah
finalement on n'aurait même pas besoin
d'atteindre jusqu'à 2021 peur parce que
vous pourrez compter sur des émissions
des titres d'état italiens et on
pourrait s'en sortir peut-être le plus
rapidement alors du coup ce que vous
pensez que lors des prochains scrutins
de vanille qui vont être primordiaux et
que ce n'est au parti a ses chances
sachant que le plus grand perdant de
cette crise sanitaire reste matteo
salvini et son parti ligue du nord je
pense que il y a il faudra voir si ce
parti est l excite à se présenter aux
élections régionales qui auront lieu le
vent et 21 septembre
mais en italie dans cette grande région
par le caire et parmi lesquels il y à la
toscane ou encore la vénétie il faudra
voir si il est qui sera des alliances
justement avec matteo salvini que de
toute façon reste le chef du premier
parti dans les sondages
et effectivement il faudra voir comment
il est le se positionne aussi sur des
thématiques plus nationale comme par
exemple à l'immigration ou encore
l'école parce que il y a beaucoup de
doutes sur la reprise normale de l'école
en septembre à cause du coût vide alors
justement à se câliner les italiens ont
encore confiance en matteo salvini après
cette crise sanitaire qui est qui a
durement touché l'italie 6 au juge les
les sondages
oui parce que effectivement la ligue
devance de quelques points aussi le
parti démocrate qui est le premier parti
de gauche de gauche et qui est
actuellement au gouvernement
on avait dit qu'effectivement le fait de
ne pas pouvoir faire des comices de
rencontrer les gens pendant le
confinement en italie avait apaisé avait
pénalisé et matteo salvini
mais en même temps on voit que le
gouvernement actuel est vraiment en
difficulté parce que sa majorité tient
qu'à un fil
il y a beaucoup de membres du parti du
mouvement 5 étoiles qui ont quitté le
parti
et puis il ne faut pas oublier aussi
qu'il ya déjà des requêtes des enquêtes
contre le premier ministre
giuseppe compter mais aussi contre un
certain nombre de ministres finalement
les italiens conseil constate que les
ministres actuels certains ministres
qu'elle se retrouve dans la même
situation où se retrouvent et matteo
salvini qui avait été accusée de navets
n'avoir pas à prêter secours avaient à
des migrants quand il avait refusé en
2018 est et en 2019 aussi et que des
navires des ong transporte de migrants
sur le territoire italien
donc il avait été obligé d'inquièter il
y à il y aura un procès mais finalement
ça pourrait être aussi celui qui va
arriver ce qui va arriver à un des
ministres les protège aussi au président
du conseil des ministres merci beaucoup
matériaux aussi de berthier d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes rédacteur en chef de putsch
médias l'espoir d'une résolution de
crise au mali après l'échec des
négociations le week-end dernier entre
la cedeao et le mouvement de
contestation du 5 juin le m5 une
nouvelle délégation est arrivé ce midi à
bamako
elle réunit les présidents nigérien
sénégalais nigérians ivoiriens et
ghanéens objectif réconcilier le
président ibrahim boubacar keïta et
l'opposition qui réclame son départ des
contestataires se sont réunis devant
l'hôtel où se tient à cette médiation
sur la sortie de crise sanitaire les
membres de l'opposition mais également
des partisans au gouvernement un sont
présents écoutez les réactions sur place
tout semble indiquer qu'ils allaient ils
étaient maison s'est décommandé à ces
chefs mal à accompagner vraiment
l'exception notable de soumaïla cissé
lui son entrée à la maison pour fêter la
fête avec ses rennes avec ma famille
avec ses amis ça fait déjà quatre ou
cinq mois c'est trop une femme qui passe
quatre mois sans nouvelle de son mari et
enfants qui sont sans nouvelles de les
faire combattre moi c'est vraiment trop
il est temps que les cinq victimes
déplacées de ce village qu'elle vous
maintenant la vie qu'elle se plaint
vraiment apprécié le parcours permet de
contredire
testé pour vous
analyse de la situation avec jean-claude
de félix tchicaya chercheur à l'institut
prospective et sécurité aux normes la
démission de monsieur becca n'est pas
dans la feuille de route de de ses
présidents des pays frontaliers avec des
présidents qui ont quand même une
autorité dans la région il manque
peut-être le le roi du maroc et le
président algérien qui sont d'ordre la
cedeao mais qui sont des pays
frontaliers et qui sont très attentifs à
la situation malienne le premier
ministre ne veut pas démissionner on
peut dire qu'une très grande partie du
mali demandes soit une des missions du
bk même si aujourd'hui elle ait pu entre
guillemets à l'ordre du jour c'est
plutôt la démission maintenant du
premier ministre et une dissolution de
l'assemblée nationale
il y a eu des les guettent sur une
première délégation de la cedeao qui a
demandé qui demandait donc que les deux
parties puissent s'entendre pour un
gouvernement d'union nationale le mali a
déjà connu des gouvernements d'union
nationale qui ont fini par imploser
donc ce qui est demandé par le mouvement
du n 5 s'est peut-être accordé le fait
que monsieur yves écarts restent pouvoir
mais lui retirer une bonne substance une
bonne partie de ses prérogatives en tant
que chef d'état donc sur le plan
juridique sur le plan narcissique même
c'est difficilement acceptable de la
part de monsieur sy beckham et il est
comme poussé à démissionner par une la
plus grande partie du mali et cette
annonce de l'elysée il ya quelques
minutes un soldat français du 1er
régiment de hussards parachutistes de
tarbes a été tué aujourd'hui au mali
dans le cadre de l'opération barkan un
communiqué de presse de la ministre des
armées et florence parly le militaire
français se trouvait dans la région de
gossip à 150 km à l'ouest de garos
lorsqu'un véhicule suicide c'est fait
explosé au contact du véhicule militaire
français deux autres militaires français
ont été blessés dans cette attaque
voilà c'est la fin de cette édition
merci à tous de l'avoir suivi prochain
point sur l'actualité dans un peu plus
de trente minutes
en attendant restez avec nous sur arte
france à tout à l'heure
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité
l'égalité des chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
alors aujourd'hui est-ce que c'est
clairement la famine qui menace le pays
nous avons d'ailleurs de la moitié de la
population qui est tombé en dessous du
seuil de pauvreté
la crise du duc ovide 19 n'a pas arrangé
la situation ne l'aurait la situation
est très mauvaise
bien avant cela ce pays a été géré en
techniques du bon sens on pouvait sans
prêter des dollars 6 7% et on est
replacé en tête d'environ du trésor et
ont pu rapporter jusqu'à près de 40%
c'est la corruption qui a mis
aujourd'hui le pays dans cet état où pas
seulement le président hariri un pic
quand il est devenu premier baudis avait
porté de 3 milliards $
et quand il a quitté ses fonctions de
ministre
sa fortune était de 17 milliards $
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
navigateur au départ est devenu alpes
unis alpinistes depuis et vous publié le
10 et du plastique avec des photos de
peter schaar afssa vient de paraître
chez favre vous êtes ambassadeur de la
fondation rice moteur alors pour
comprendre le problème du plastique
il se trouve dans ce livre il ya des
liens vers des films on va regarder un
petit extrait une sorte de génériques
[Musique]
c'est donc cette odyssée que raconte ce
livre le la question que l'on se pose
aujourd'hui c'est comment lutter contre
la pollution des océans par le plastique
parce que le problème n'est pas
seulement esthétique c'est un problème
bien plus grave
non c'est même pas esthétique parce
qu'en fait c'est pas finalement ce
convoi qui est plus dangereux
d'ailleurs le problème c'est que
lorsqu'on est ligue dans les océans
finalement croiser pas grand chose non
mais quand on parle de ce continent de
plastique en fait on ne le voit pas
alors c'est une belle image parce que au
moins celle avantage de de mobiliser les
gens il leur faire comprendre qu'il ya
vrai problème c'est effectivement on
croise pas enfin céder les solutions des
produits le plastique ça ça existe
depuis les années 50 donc ça fait depuis
très longtemps qu'on le jette dans
l'océan après c'est une critique facile
parce que il ya une trentaine d'années
de toute façon ceux qui paient pas
d'environnement et c'est vrai qu'on
faisait pas vraiment attention à ce que
l'on jetait dans les fleuves et qui vont
directement dans la mer oui on disait
juste c'est moche c'est moche sauf que
ça s'est accumulé on s'aperçoit
maintenant que pasa se dissout et que
ses impacts complètement là la faune la
flore c'était si on parle du plancton ça
c'est vraiment important parce que c'est
assez récent de savoir que le donc les
micros et leino plastique qui sont
dissous dans les